[Musique]
bonjour à tous pour un congrès j'allais
dire extraordinaire c'est pas le cas
dans les statuts dans les statuts c'est
notre congrès statutaire ordinaire tous
les trois ans mais il est extraordinaire
par la période que nous traversons par
les contraintes que cette période nous
impose
il est extraordinaire aussi en tout cas
marqué de grandes émotions parce que
l'actualité a fait que cette semaine
nous avons vécu la disparition de valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a évidemment été
pour cette grande famille du centre
france est une figure une personnalité
une aventure extraordinaire que beaucoup
d'entre nous partager et qui explique
donc la raison pour laquelle ce congrès
sera marquée aussi d'une grande émotion
d'un sentiment de gravité de
responsabilité en raison de la situation
du pays et d'une grande émotion en
raison de cet événement qui a je crois
beaucoup ému les français c'est un
congrès à distance pas distance pour
tout le monde tout à l'heure le premier
ministre par exemple viendra s'exprimer
à ma place sur cette tribune qui est à
moitié virtuel à moitié réelle dans
notre siège mais viendront aussi à
distance tous les responsables de notre
mouvement j'adresse un salut affectueux
à marielle qui s'exprimera pour la
première fois depuis cinq mois
tout à l'heure
lors de la clôture de cette rencontre
aux membres du gouvernement de notre
famille politique
alors je salue jacqueline gourault je
salue marc fesneau
je salue geneviève darrieussecq je salue
sarah elle a écrit et il
ils s'exprimeront et je salue évidemment
tous les responsables de notre maison
et puis tous les membres du gouvernement
s'exprimeront et puis vont s'exprimer
aussi tous les responsables de terrain
de l'organisation de notre maison jean
noël barrot notre secrétaire général et
puis tous ceux parmi les parlementaires
parmi les groupes de l'assemblée
nationale du sénat qui vont participer
aux débats qui sont les nôtres et donc
ceci est évidemment inédit mais très
important et vous allez pouvoir y
participer de manière interactive
puisque c'est ainsi que ce congrès a été
conçu c'est un congrès vous le voyez
bien et les membres du gouvernement le
savez les parlementaires le savent et
chacun d'entre nous citoyens élus locaux
ou citoyens de l'animation de la
démocratie citoyen de base comme on dit
mais c'est à la base que la démocratie
se décident chacun d'entre nous nous y
participons parce que nous vivons tous
ensemble une crise d'une gravité
absolument sans précédent en tout cas
sans précédent depuis la guerre et sans
précédent aussi par sa nature puisque
c'est une crise absolument inattendu qui
surgit brutalement sur une planète qui
avait bâti son équilibre sur un
développement fondé sur
les échanges et on avait l'impression
que ce développement et est irrésistible
et que cette organisation aussi et été
irrésistible que rien ne pourrait la
mettre à mal et puis on s'aperçoit que
un simple virus c'est-à-dire un million
de fois plus petit qu'un grain de sable
un simple virus vient mettre à bas ce
que deux siècles de développement avait
organisé à la surface de la planète avec
tous les avantages et tous les risques
d'un développement de cette ampleur et
cette crise d'abord sanitaires à la
naturellement aussi aujourd'hui des
conséquences dont chacun d'entre nous
sait qu'elles vont être extrêmement
lourdes conséquences économiques
conséquences sociales conséquence
démocratique et tout au long de la
journée nous allons réfléchir à ses
conséquences et à cette crise par
exemple le fait que cette crise est
bloqué nos concitoyens dans le
confinement
c'est à dire dans leur lieu de résidence
et dans leur lieu de travail est rendu
plus difficile le travail en commun et
organiser le travail à distance
tout cela va avoir évidemment des
conséquences très importantes sur
l'organisation du territoire du pays
le les grandes unités urbaines vont
avoir des difficultés inédites et
peut-être un nouvel l'aménagement du
territoire va s'imposer et en tout cas
c'est évidemment de cela que nous allons
que nous allons parler et ça veut dire
aussi que notre démocratie est mise à
l'épreuve qui va falloir en inventer des
formes nouvelles
ça veut dire que les grands chantiers de
réformes que nous avions initiée que le
gouvernement avait initié l que le
président de la république
avait initié ces grands chantiers de
réformes ils sont aujourd'hui sur le
métier comment les porter comment les
faire aboutir dans quel calendrier
sachant aussi que bien entendu nous
allons nous rapprocher de l'élection
présidentielle qui sera organisée dans
18 mois
voilà les soucis d'un parti politique et
d'un parti politique est un parti qui
compte dans la majorité qui est un des
piliers de la majorité et nous aurons
aussi des débats sur l'organisation de
cette majorité
qui est forcément une question qui se
pose aux forces politiques les
oppositions sont divisés il faut que la
majorité soient le plus unis possible et
en même temps qu'elle sache additionner
les forces des mouvements différents qui
l'a formé notamment de des mouvements
qui a été créée par le président de la
république en marche et de notre
mouvement à nous le mouvement démocrate
qui est son allié
voilà des sujets
ces sujets là sont pas uniquement des
sujets nationaux ils sont des sujets
planétaire et ils sont des sujets
européens et nos parlementaires
européens en plus des députés des
sénateurs de notre mouvement vont aussi
s'exprimer sur ces sujets avec la
conscience qu'ils portent en tout cas
que les institutions européennes portent
une part très importante des réponses
qui sont celles de notre avenir national
voilà c'est un congrès sous une forme
inédite mais c'est un congrès de plein
exercice il y a eu le renouvellement des
instances départementales et nationales
nous en aurons tout à l'heure mais les
résultats mais je reconnais qu'il y
avait pas un suspense extraordinaire
pour l'élection du président et je vous
en demande pardon mais c'est comme ça
que c'était organisé avec les règles qui
sont les nôtres
je suis très heureux que cette rencontre
puisse avoir lieu je veux remercier les
équipes qui ont rendu possible cette
organisation qui ont eu l'imagination la
capacité le dévouement l'engagement de
rendre possible cette organisation est
donc tout à l'heure vous allez entendre
ce que vous avez porté aux
responsabilités je veux remercier
particulièrement les membres du
gouvernement parce que leurs emplois du
temps n'est pas facile et donc marc
raynaud jacqueline gourault nathalie et
limaces sarah est la hérie et geneviève
darrieussecq sont spécialement remercier
de même que les parlementaires sont
spécialement remercier ils sont tous sur
le terrain
j'espère qu'ils vont cependant prendre
le temps de participer à cette rencontre
merci à tous j'ouvre je déclare ouvert
le congrès du mouvement démocrate
merci